dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here
due to popular request here is a more
intuitive explanation of our latest work
believe it or not when I have started
working on this two minute papers didn't
even exist in several research areas
there are cases where we can talk about
our work until it is published I knew
that the paper would not see the light
of the day for quite a while if ever so
I started two minute papers to be able
to keep my sanity and deliver a
hopefully nice piece of work on a
regular basis in the end this took more
than three thousand work hours to
complete but it is finally here and I am
so happy to finally be able to present
it to you this work is in the
intersection of computer graphics and AI
which you know is among my favorites so
what do we see here this beautiful scene
contains more than a hundred different
materials each of which has been learned
and synthesized by an AI none of these
daisies and then the Lions are alike
each of them have a different material
model the goal is to teach an AI the
concept of material models such as
metals minerals and translucent
materials traditionally when we are
looking to create a new material model
with a light simulation program we have
to fiddle with quite a few parameters
and whenever we change something we have
to wait from 40 to 60 seconds until a
noise free result appears in our
solution we don't need to play with
these parameters instead our goal is to
grab a gallery of random materials
assign a score to each of them saying
that I like this one I didn't like that
one and get an AI to learn our
preferences and recommend new materials
for us this is quite useful when we are
looking to synthesize not only one but
many materials so this is learning
algorithm number one and it works really
well for a variety of materials however
these recommendations still have to be
rendered with a light simulation program
which takes several hours for a gallery
like the one you see here here come's
learning algorithm number two to the
rescue a neural network that replaces
this light simulation program and
creates photorealistic visualizations it
is so fast it not only does this in real
time but it is more than ten times
faster than real time we call this a
neural renderer so we have a lot of
material recommendations and they are
all photorealistic that we can visualize
in real time however it is always a
possibility that we have a
recommendation that is almost exactly
what we had in mind but need a few
adjustments that's an issue because to
do that we would have to go back to the
parameter feed link which we really
wanted to avoid in the first place no
worries because the third learning
algorithm is coming to the rescue what
this can do is take our favorite
material models from the gallery and map
them onto a nice 2d plane where we can
explore similar materials if we combine
this with the neuro renderer we can
explore these photorealistic
visualizations and everything appears
not in a few hours but in real time
however without a little further
guidance we get a bit lost because we
still don't know which regions in this
2d space are going to give us materials
that are similar to the one we wish to
fine-tune we can further improve this by
exploring different combinations of the
three learning algorithms in the end we
can assign these colors to the
background that describe either whether
the AI expects us to like the output or
how similar the output will be
a nice use case of this is where we have
this glass is still live scene but the
color of the grapes is a bit too vivid
for us now we can go to this 2d Leighton
space and adjust it to our liking in
real time
much better no material modeling
expertise is required so I hope you
found this explanation intuitive we
tried really hard to create something
that is both scientifically novel and
also useful for the computer game and
motion picture industry we have to throw
away hundreds of other ideas until this
final system materialized make sure to
have a look at the paper in the
description where every single element
and learning algorithm is tested and
evaluated one by one if you are a
journalist and you would like to write
about this work I would be most grateful
and I am also more than happy to answer
questions in an interview format as well
please reach out if you are interested
we also try to give back to the
community so for the fellow thinkers out
there the entirety of the paper is under
the permissive Creative Commons license
and the full source code and pre-trained
networks are also available under the
even more permissive MIT license
everyone is welcome to reuse it or build
something cool on top of it thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time